[Music]
The Fortunes of Africa's wealthiest
people have rebounded slightly in the
past 12 months reversing the decline in
their fortunes from a year ago though
they are still off their all-time highs
from
2022 the 20 billionaires on the 2024
Forbes list of Africa's richest are
worth a combined $82.4
billion that's up $900 million from last
year's 81.5 billion however all of that
gain can be attributed to the return of
n ia's FEI otola who last appeared on
the Africa list in
2017 this year South Africa claims six
spots on the ranking followed by Egypt
with five and Nigeria with four Algeria
Tanzania and Zimbabwe each have one
billionaire on the list while Morocco
has two here are Africa's top five
billionaires for
2024 number five Mike adenuga adenuga is
Nigeria's second second richest man and
he built his fortune in
telecommunications and oil production
his mobile phone network globacom is the
second largest operator in Nigeria with
more than 60 million
subscribers globacom also built glow1 a
6,100 m long submarine internet cable
that runs to the UK via Ghana and
Portugal his oil exploration outfit con
oil producing operates six oil blocks in
the Nyro
Delta number four nasf
suis nasf suis is an investor and a
Scion of Egypt's wealthiest family with
a net worth of $8.7
billion in December 2020 he acquired a
5% stake in New York listed firm Madison
Square Garden Sports owner of the NBA's
Knicks and the NHL's Rangers his
Holdings include a nearly 6% stake in
German sportsware firm
Adidas he also runs oci one of the
world's largest nitrogen fertilizer
producers which has plants in Texas and
Iowa number three Nikki Oppenheimer and
family Nikki Oppenheimer heir to the
debers diamond Fortune was the third
generation of his family to run to beers
and he took the company private in 2001
for 85 years the Oppenheimer family
occupied a controlling spot in the
world's Diamond trade then in 2012
Nikki Oppenheimer sold his 40% of the
firm to mining group anglo-american for
$5.1 billion in cash in 2014 Oppenheimer
started Fireblade aviation in
Johannesburg which operates chartered
flights and he owns at least 720 square
miles of conservation land across South
Africa batswana Zimbabwe and mosm
Beek number two Johan Rupert and
family this South African luxury goods
owner held on to the number two spot
this year with $10.1 billion down from
10.7 billion in 2023 as shares of his
company financier richmont
slip the company is best known for its
Brands Cartier and mon Blanc and it was
formed in 1998 through a spin-off of
assets owned by remgro limited a company
which his father Anton formed in the
1940s
Rupert owns 7% of Diversified investment
firm remrow which he chairs as well as
26% of rayet an investment holding
company based in
Luxembourg he has been a vocal opponent
of plans to allow fracking in the kuu a
region of South Africa where he owns
land number one aliko
dangote dangote is Africa's richest
person and the founder of dangote cement
the continent's largest cement producer
he owns 85% of publicly traded dangote
cement through a holding
company after many years in development
dangote's fertilizer plant in Nigeria
began operations in March 2022 and his
dangote Refinery is expected to begin
refining operations in
2024 his fortune Rose by $400 million
this year to 13.9 billion and he claimed
the rankings number one spot for the
13th year in a row
[Music]